can I help you never in my address I'm
not an uber Oh have a good night what
are you doing in yes near my uber I'm
not a new the driver really is for an
uber driver I'm not a stupid driver then
where was your car long gap okay I got
it
[Music]
are you my over I can be okay shake me
wings
[Music]
well actually I'm doing with a little
bit of stomachache right now there's
talk to last night really not stick you
to well you know what I'm talking about
but kind of my Amanda I got to pick this
rhyme by hey there we go yes well
actually I ran into this guy earlier and
you such a jerk
[Music]
Amanda hey yeah yeah yeah roses I got
them for you I'm allergic
I made us dinner Mary I was fine so I
went out last night and my sidekick
texted me she's so beautiful may or may
not is it that no wonder she like no we
definitely hooked up like that time
amazing I got you something a balloon
I love you oh wait I'm going me later
see you later
hey don't worry it's my best friend's
mom
oh we're basically dating good night
do you have any we're sleeping on it no
it's my last one she forgets ignored the
whole night
that's annoying all right good night why
not Alan nice that's the elephant the
pink one you just gotta cut in your
sleep talking right now
oh really copier with the fog I thought
you just said you didn't have any
sleeping problems
mm sorry you're not gonna do it again
right and I'll put my hand in here you
sure look delay manner
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what a sweet bang look I'm a cut right
to the chase because I live life in the
fast lane Oh interesting I like fast
cars fast money woman because I Drive
that I earn fast and I'd bang her and I
want to take you home
I'm sorry what did you just say I like
fast cars in it
no I heard all that was the last thing
that he said oh I beg that you wouldn't
even feel a thing that's not a good
thing but you shouldn't brag about that
why because the girl needs to have
pleasure too you lost me when a guy and
a girl are making love the girl and the
guy need to feel pleasure can't just
think about yourself now just make
another oh my god have a nice plate oh
[Music]
you know I'm so glad this worked out
when I first asked you out I didn't
think you'd say yes how could I say no
to a handsome doctor like you that you
get a lot of weird cases yeah do you
ever get anywhere somebody you know has
a sore throat that's a pretty common
thing that people have totally yeah what
the runny nose I don't know
yeah is that weird for them to have like
a fever with that that's a cold you're
describing a cold now somebody had that
though how would you teacher it you know
I'm not that kind of doctor
well I was just curious so um so tell me
like what did you actually know of
anybody that's that kind of doc
and it's single are you just writing in
medical advice for me I don't know okay
I'm out of here
wait wait can you still write
prescriptions through ahem
sure he's crazy so here you go
$68 that means our days will be 50 I
only had one drink
sorry you're like 3.1 didn't I start
wearing glasses oh yeah I got it you
think love is a 13 any face 50 righteous
Brenda makes my name is three dollars
girls you already visited two through
see you just said from three dollars
oh you're so good we should give them
one more use Mackin oh use a nice lady
keep the change
[Music]